[Musique]
déjà plus d'un an que the last of est
partie 2 a été annoncé et très peu
d'infos nous ont été partagés ce jeu
risque d'être un chef-d'oeuvre autant
que son prédécesseur et j'aimerais vous
proposer un 3 théorie car malgré
seulement 2 trailer nous pouvons
adéquatement faire quelques suppositions
mais avant tout que savons-nous
exactement sur ce last of us de
l'histoire se passe cinq ans après le
premier elie possède donc 19 ans et joël
environ 55 ans l'histoire semblerait se
tourner autour de l'histoire des lits et
qu'elle est très en colère après un
groupe de personnes joël veille toujours
sur elle et nous suivrons leur aventure
bref je vois pas trop quoi rajouter sans
devoir théorisé donc un menon les
théories
un trailer plutôt intriguant est sorti
il ya maintenant trois mois mettant en
scène de nouveaux personnages inconnus
jusqu'à ce jour dont deux jeunes
protagonistes asiatique est une jeune
femme prête à être pendue du nom de
laura bei et de femmes sont capturées
par trois protagonistes semblablement
considérés comme les méchants et se font
au final tu es pas relève le jeune
garçon cependant avant son intervention
le groupe de mauvaise personne voulait
pendre à moitié l'aura et la punir pour
ses péchés
la femme commence à planter un couteau
dans le ventre de la jeune femme
en prononçant ces mots ses péchés serait
alors dans son ventre
d'après ce que nous pouvons comprendre
juste avant que la petite fille
interviennent le groupe de méchants
pourrait en vouloir à laura pour ce
qu'elle a dans le ventre
on pourrait donc imaginer qu'elle est
enceinte le groupe d'antagonistes
pourraient être des gens appartenant à
un groupe éliminant des types de
personnes précise en rapport avec leurs
croyances et leur religion
d'après ce que nous voyons elle semble
clairement lui en vouloir pour ce
qu'elle a dans le ventre on dirait les
autres cadavres n'ont pas le ventre des
coupes et flora doit certainement cacher
quelque chose et le groupe voulait
certainement la tuer pour éviter que des
gens de son espèce se reproduise ou je
ne sais quoi
bref ils lui en veulent maintenant
rappelez-vous dana hanna est la mère des
lits et je vous en avais déjà parlé dans
mon trois théories sur the last of us
qui commence d'ailleurs à dater laura
serait donc la maman délits comme
premier argument rappelez-vous des
easter egg partager via naughty dog 1
était cachée dans le premier the last of
us annonçant uncharted cats qui fut
s'avérait être le prochain jeu prévue
par naughty dog et bizarrement dans
uncharted cat un easter egg montrait un
poster avec une femme enceinte est écrit
the last of americans doubt heures
les théories des fans étaient donc déjà
lancé que the last of us 2 montrerait la
mère d'élise lorsqu'elle était enceinte
soit anna c'est un argument majeur
ensuite si nous reprenons le premier
trailer partagés sur the last of us
partie de nous voyons et lee en colère
qui aimerais-tu et chacun d'entre eux si
nous roulions ceci au deuxième trailer
de the last of us de on pourrait penser
qu elle y parle du groupe qui a torturé
voire même plus encore laura bailey y
soit anna d'après la théorie donc la
mère d'élise ils ont fait souffrir sa
mère est certainement tué car dans the
last of us premier du nom anna est
déclarée morte c'est aussi un argument
majeur
enfin pour terminer je vous avoue que la
première fois que j'ai vu ce trailer
j'ai cru que laura était elie ii par la
ressemblance puis je me suis rendu
compte que c'était une autre personne
le plus intrigant reste un tweet de
naughty dog hype en encore plus la
communauté de fans
ces derniers déclarent laura bellei is
ce tweet prouve bien que ce personnage
n'est pas là par hasard et que son
identité ait caché
d'où le laura bailey qui serait en fait
anna la mer délit
l'intrigué réellement présente et je
suis curieux de voir ce que naughty dog
nous proposer à son sujet bref passons à
la suite
[Musique]
nous ne savons rien du scénario prévu
pour the last of us 2 on ne connaît même
pas sa date de sortie
pourtant quelque chose me dit que nous
allons avoir un jeu avec un double
scénario de thriller nous ont été
montrés à dans le présent où il y à 19
ans et un autre où nous voyons laura bei
qui seraient normalement la mer délit
personnellement je pense que the last of
us 2 sera comme final fantasy 8 pour les
connaisseurs en gros dans final fantasy
8 nous incarnons school et son groupe
mais à plusieurs moments du scénario
pour comprendre l'histoire et les
détails nous sommes ramenés dans le
passé par le biais des lônes pour nous
montrer les aventures de laguna le père
de school le jeu interverti entre l'
aventure du présent de squall le fils et
le passé avec les aventures de laguna
son père eh bien je pense sincèrement
que the last of us 2 sera du même type
d'après les deux trailer on pourrait
supposer que nous vivrions une histoire
dans le présent avec elie qui
souhaiteraient connaître ses origines et
venger sa mère qui fut mal traités et
même tuer cependant en avançant dans
l'histoire et au cours de l' enquête
délits sur ses origines
on serait amené à vivre des scènes du
passé où nous incarnons riom laura bei
la mère d'élise et nous vivrions son
histoire ses aventures et sa période de
grossesse et peut-être même qui serait
le père d'élise je pense sincèrement que
le jeu se tournera vers l'histoire délit
que nous ne connaissons que très peu au
final contrairement à joël auquel on
sait déjà énormément de choses sur son
passé mais rien sur elie elie cherchera
donc ses origines dans the last of us 2
avec joël pour veiller sur elle et
revivre des scènes du passé de cette
dernière d'ailleurs apparemment ellis
sereine et en 2018 dans l'histoire du
jeu quoi de mieux qu'une histoire sur sa
famille pour ce deuxième opus prévu pour
fin d'année ou début 2019 comme par
hasard cependant nous viserions aussi la
mort de la mère d'élise si nous suivons
son histoire car vous le savez elle est
décédée dans le premier the last of us
donc avant les 14 ans délit je suis
content que naughty dog tournerait
possiblement le jeu vers elie qui est
réellement un personnage très attachant
on savait déjà énormément sur joël mais
pas sur elle j'espère avoir raison dans
ce cas là
[Musique]
oui le bigot
pour cette dernière théorie j'aimerais
retourner sur the last of us premier du
nom vous le savez et lee a été recueilli
par marlène chef des lucioles
il est dit qu apparemment c'est sa mère
qui a confié elie à marlène et qu'elle
possède un pouvoir très spécial celui
que vous connaissez tous qu'elle est
immunisée contre les infectés mais qui
nous dit que marley ne nous a pas menti
c'est elle qui dit que c'est la mère
délit qui lui a confié sa fille elle a
fait croire à elie énormément de choses
au point qu'elle ici réfèrerait comme si
elle était sa propre mère alors qu'en
fait marlène se servaient des lits
depuis le début juste pour posséder un
sérum pour contrer l'épidémie d'infecter
marlène est doué pour le mensonge et les
coups par derrière et elle l'a déjà
montré à plusieurs reprises
alors pourquoi lui faire confiance qui
nous dit que ce n'est pas elle et son
groupe des lucioles qui aurait tué la
mère delhi pour s'emparer d'elle
justement est donc posséder l'antidote
contre l'infection réexpliquer encore
plus de choses déjà quand joe est sauvée
lit dans ce last of us premier du nom il
tue seulement marlène les lucioles sont
toujours un groupe actif donc il se
pourrait qu'un ou une autre et pris la
place de marlène et soit le nouveau
leader
puis cela pourrait expliquer la colère
des lits après tout elle était très
attachée à marlène de la pourrait
résonner pour elle comme une traîtrise
sans oublier que joël lui a menti sur
l'opération pour finalement la sauver
joël devra forcément lui dire la vérité
un moment ou un autre
la colère délit pourrait signifier
qu'elle veut tuer le groupe des lucioles
définitivement et prendre sa revanche
sur ces derniers qui aurait tué sa mère
j'ai un argument clé pour vous le
prouver
si vous revoyez le premier trailer de
the last of us partie de nous sommes
dans une ville déserte fouillé par joël
et ely cependant avant d apercevoir nous
sommes face à un panneau avec le symbole
des lucioles ce symbole sur le panneau
montre que ces derniers sont passés par
là et ont habité les lieux
ensuite et lino dit qu'elle veut tuer
chacun d'entre eux pour moi cela veut
tout dire
ils sont sur la trace des lucioles pour
justement les traquer et les tuer et
sont arrivés et dans l'un de leurs
anciens camps et vont poursuivre leur
route
pourquoi elle est ici dans un endroit
normalement fréquenté par les lucioles
et en plus avec une telle rage au fond
des lits c'est une mise en scène
réellement explicite et j'espère avoir
été clair dans ce que je voulais dire
enfin pour terminer si laura bailey ya
la mer délit et que le groupe de
méchants faisait partie des lucioles
cela veut dire que ces derniers
voulaient certainement lui découper le
ventre pour s'emparer des lits car
quelque chose était peut-être mystérieux
comme un sérum détecter via le foetus
pourquoi pas ou peut-être empêché cette
dernière d'avoir un enfant car elle
était déjà peut être prédisposés dans
ses gênes à posséder un sérum est donc
seul a atterri sur la génération des
lions ne sais pas en tout cas j'espère
que mes mystère et mes théories vous
auront plus ce last of us m'a réellement
marqué et fait partie pour moi du saint
graal du jeu vidéo
je suis certain que le deuxième opus
sera aussi incroyable que le premier
même si nous n'aurons pas la surprise de
l'aide découvert cette fois ci faisons
confiance à naughty dog
merci à ceux qui laisseront un pouce
bleus et qui partageront la vidéo
n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur twitter
pour les plus acharnés d'entre vous
c'est et argo rock et que le line up
soit avec vous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]